Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explain
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talk to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
I thought I'd do something
interesting today, which I was.
I was looking back at the
previous episodes and I saw that
almost a year ago today I did an
episode called the Future of CFD
Five key trends to watch.
It was season 2 episode 2 and I
thought I will try and do
another version of that and
basically see a year on, was I
right or was I wrong?
So what I had as the five were
the rise of GPUs in CFD, AI and
machine learning, shift to cloud
computing, digital
certification, and I think I had
the last one which was mergers
and acquisitions.
OK, Now this was before I joined
NVIDIA.
Oh, I should just say.
So obviously NVIDIA's you know,
creates GPUs.
So the rise of GPUs in CFD.
Can I answer that while being
completely unbiased?
Probably not, but it's true.
Basically, there has been an
unbelievable rise in GPUs for CFD. I.
Can say that even if I wasn't
working for NVIDIA, I think
people in the community know
that to be the case.
Has that accelerated in the past
year?
Yes, most definitely it is.
Yeah.
Just the number one question.
And again, I know I work for
NVIDIA, so I'm going to say
that, but it's true.
I go to conferences and I see it
without me even talking to them.
You know, they're showing slides
saying, OK, it's 10 times faster
on a GPU. I did not get involved
in that study whatsoever.
I'm just sat there listening to
it.
So it it is absolutely the case.
And as anything there was, it
was slower at the beginning.
People were like, OK, is this
really true?
You know, is this marketing?
I think now there's been so many
independent studies showing it
that people are fully getting
behind.
And I think what's also made the
difference is 1, the hardware's
obviously keeps getting better
and better.
The pace of GPUs, because
obviously AI has helped.
This is far out pacing.
CPUs in terms of like
generational generation, you
know, like the improvement that
you get each generation is, is
like this compared to CPUs,
which is, you know, a bit
slower.
So you're, by moving to it, you
keep getting better and better.
So the reason to move has
probably accelerated.
I think the, there's been a
healthy competition between
different CFD companies each
seeing GPUs to be part of
that differentiating thing.
And that has created a, a sort
of an acceleration, you know,
because there's one vendor
releases a GPU version, everyone
wants to make sure they also
have one.
So there's been a little bit of
that, but for good reasons.
It's not purely, you know, just
for the sake of it.
It's because people are
genuinely seeing a speed up
customers liking it and and
therefore they're doing it.
And I think most interestingly,
which is I think something I
commented on is there's a lot of
start-ups now who are
specifically focusing entirely on being
GPU native.
And that has also definitely
created a shift because no
surprise if you write code from
scratch with a sort of software–hardware co-design, you're
going to create something really
good.
And so because of those
start-ups, they have shown in
some ways the like most optimal
solution and has really shown
some very interesting
performance.
What I find more at a technical
level interesting is where the
whole like unstructured implicit
finite volume, which I guess was
the industry standard does that.
Is that the most optimum
numerical approach on GPUs?
It could be, but because they're
so much more powerful and
because of that, you can start
to do more transient high
fidelity LES, then people are
going, well, if I'm going to do
an LES and I'm going to have to
run lots of time steps and I've
got this GPU, should I maybe now
go back to explicit that
previously wasn't maybe the
optimum way of doing it, but now
with the GPU it is.
And then maybe could I do a, a
wall-modelled approach if I'm
doing a wall-modelled LES, and does
that mean I should maybe use the
immersed-boundary method because I
don't need to resolve the wall?
And so that it's this interplay
between the hardware and the
software is creating some really
interesting changes.
And and finally, one of the
interesting was a high order
side, You know, I think high
order, without going into too
much of the technical details,
there's some interesting stuff
around like tensor cores,
etcetera.
So the whole high order thing is
coming back in to play.
So yeah, was my prediction of
key trends for CFD correct, GPUs
and CFD, I'd say yes.
And is it still for 2025/26?
Definitely.
It's only accelerating and I
think you'll find that it
continues to accelerate whilst
there is so much more learnings
to be had in terms of optimal
architectures.
And there's like a crossover
point when your compute gets
higher, you can go to a
different modeling paradigm.
So for example, and not wanted
to speak about this for too
long, you've gone from, let's
say a wall-resolved RANS, like a
low-y+ RANS, where you wanted
to resolve the wall and where
you need a certain gridding
strategy to be able to resolve
the wall to a wall-modelled LES
where you say, oh, well, I don't
need to resolve the wall because
I'm modelling it.
So maybe I can go to a different
gridding paradigm and I can go
to explicit.
But if you go to the next stage,
which is the wall-resolved LES,
that maybe say, well, actually
now my gridding paradigm that
was good for wall-modelled LES may
not be good for wall-resolved
LES.
Maybe I need to do something
slightly different.
So it's interesting how these
waves happen and the, like I
said, doesn't interplay.
So what I find most interesting
is a year ago or two years ago,
the most bold predictions was
more towards hybrid RANS/LES,
wall-modelled and everyone said
oh, wall-resolved is too far
away.
I'm actually seeing now people
be a bit bolder and say, well,
you know what with the latest GPUs,
maybe wall-resolved LES,
it started to become possible.
And that's interesting.
I think not for everyday
applications perhaps, but now
that that is coming up, some
other stuff starts to get
interesting like just the sheer
number of time steps you need to
do.
And yeah, so still important.
OK, AI, machine learning.
Well, duh.
Yeah, that's clearly still a key
trend.
Has things moved up in the last
year?
Absolutely.
I'd say one of the big
breakthroughs I personally seen
is probably a year ago or a little before a year ago, one of
the bottlenecks seemed to be
volume prediction using AI
surrogates.
Stuff was coming out around like
graph neural networks and being able
to predict things, but all the
examples were always on smaller
cases.
And one of the things that I did
with some colleagues was to
create that DrivAerML data set,
which was really put out there
as a data set to give
realistically sized meshes and
hopefully encourage people to
see, right.
Can my method take the entire
volume and a year or certainly
two years ago, it looked like
not many people could do it.
Everyone was just doing the
surface or maybe a few slices
and every time you saw
something, you know in marketing
online, it was always like the
surface of the car or a slice of
the car.
What I found was a breakthrough in
the past year is that various
methods have come out and I
guess the most, most most recent
will be like Transformers that
seem to be the most
computationally efficient.
Efficient for doing full volume
predictions as in training on a
full volume and then doing an
inference and being able to get
a full volume out.
I feel like that really
accelerated the realization that
some of these AI methods could
give you back a flow field that
was more similar to a
traditional one.
And yeah, that transition from
from graph networks to maybe neural
operators and Transformers for
me has been a really interesting
1.
And I'm certainly excited to see
what happens in the next year.
I think we'll continue to see
new architectures, new evolution
of, of AI.
So that is definitely a trend
that's continuing.
Yeah.
And they're obviously linked,
right.
So if you have a faster solver,
you can generate data more
easily.
You can then do the training.
I think one of the big
discussions now is on the right
code architecture.
Sorry, like programming
environment, because online
training is definitely a hot
topic.
You know, how can you take
advantage of the transient
nature of the flow?
So at the moment, I'd say the
state-of-the-art is normally
that you would just generate
those data and even if it was
with a hybrid RANS or wall-modelled LES, you'll just take a
time average and dump that and
train on that.
But I think what's emerging now
is this interesting, well, can I
use some of the transient data
that's being created anyway, you
know, dump them out at
checkpoint and train on that.
So I think the whole AI will
continue and continue.
The one thing that I would
probably add to that AI bucket
is the agentic AI side.
So let's say you've got
surrogates that's in one market
and you've got LLMs for just
general productivity gains and
coding on the other.
I put agentic AI somewhere in
the middle, which is how can you
have multiple agents working
autonomously through some sort
of master agent that can go off
and do tasks for you.
So instead of you having to
manually click run this
simulation or write a Python
code that goes and runs, you'd
said, give a text prompt saying
I would like to go and run this
simulation with these parameters
and please create me a report.
And you'll have a workflow where
an agent will interpret that
request will then go and let's
say create a simulation setup
for you.
But crucially also then run the
simulation, let's say an HPC
cluster, use a separate, you
know, agent could be a surrogate
model essentially, you know, to
go run it or to do the meshing,
then another LLM, maybe do the
analysis of the results.
And the point being is that you
have to kick that all off with a text prompt.
That is the most cutting edge
example.
And that's what I feel is
probably in the next 12 months
will be the next big jump.
And some start-ups are already
doing it as some companies, but
I feel that's probably one of
the big next steps.
I should add, by the way, for GPUs
I didn't mention, I think
precision is a very interesting
topic now.
I think there's huge gains if
CFD can use lower precision for
for obvious reasons, you know,
that there's so many FLOPS in in the
lower precision because of AI
generally only needs, you know,
FP8 or FP16.
So it doesn't mean that you
can't do 64 or 32, but if you
can find a way to harness that
power, then you can really
unlock the next big accelerator.
So the first one I had was the
shift to cloud computing.
Now, you know, people who know
me or listened to this before
know that you know, I currently
work from NVIDIA, but I used to
work for Amazon Web Services,
which is obviously a massive
cloud computing company.
And there is no doubt whatsoever
that cloud computing has totally
transformed the IT sector and
the HPC sector.
When I left AWS. I definitely saw
an increasing momentum in people
adopting the cloud cause of the
fact that they could essentially
focus on the stuff that mattered
to them and not on the sort of
manual data centre stuff.
I still see that increasing, but
probably the bit that maybe I
was not brainwashed because I'm
joking aside a little bit.
But you I definitely, I'm seeing
I'm still a more hybrid sense
where on one hand people are
absolutely seeing the value of
the cloud, you know, through
AWS or GCP or Microsoft or you
know, all the cloud players.
And by the way, there's an
interesting angle now with all
these neoclouds like CoreWeave, etcetera, which is mainly
I guess to the AI and GPU angle, but I'm still seeing a
hybrid use.
You know, there's still quite a
lot of on Prem, there's cloud
and and I still think there's a
lot of room for improvements in
the way to access cloud
resources.
You know, I think SaaS from a CFD
point of view now SaaS products
are still not fully there.
You know, if you ask most people
are they doing it software
service?
No, they may use the cloud to
have a cluster, but are they
doing it in a true SaaS like
manner?
I think that it's slower than I
thought people still seem to
prefer and there's good reason.
So we'd have to get into of
having a local experience in
that you're not just doing
through a web browser.
And I think that's probably just
decades of engineers being used
to just SSH-ing and stuff and
and having like, yeah, running
scripts.
And it's something that you
think would change, but it, it
does seem remarkably stubborn.
And yeah, so I, I definitely see
the cloud continuing, but I'm
still waiting for some company
to come out there and really
make it easy from a workflow
point of view in like a true
hybrid way or to just simplify
maybe the cloud experience.
You still have to be quite an
expert to do it.
So I am, I'm not changing that
prediction.
I'm just seeing that it seems to
be a bit slower than I fully
appreciated.
And maybe in hindsight, that's
because I was seeing all of the
positive and success stories at
AWS and maybe I was not hearing
the bits where people weren't,
you know, doing it.
The 4th 1 I had was on digital
certification through higher-fidelity methods that, as I
mentioned on the 3rd of it is
definitely the case.
You know, you're having a huge
increase of people going to
higher fidelity methods because
of #1 you know, the fact that
you can access to compute more
easily.
And that is definitely a topic
that I think will continue to
increase sector by sector.
So the automotive has definitely
pioneered that and all have
moved to higher fidelity
methods.
I think now, like I said,
they're, they're looking how can
I go from hybrid RANS to wall-
resolved LES.
I think the aerospace sector is
probably still trying to get
from RANS, you know, to hybrid RANS or
wall-modelled LES and the work
that you know, we did in the
last High Lift Prediction Workshop
has definitely helped to push
that forward.
And there's some interesting
work going on now to try and
push it even further again to
like wall-resolved LES.
But I see that continually, you
know, increasing and now it's
more around building up best
practices and understanding of
those methods, you know,
robustness that everybody knows
where they go wrong, where they
go right.
So it probably will take time
for that and for people to see
the value because it is
undeniably more expensive to do
with the low fidelity.
So I think there needs to be
success stories that have been
created.
But I think probably one of the
biggest challenges is
transition.
Certainly I'm speaking more from
a CFD and external aero point of
view, but one of the challenges
still with even going to
wall-modelled LES to hybrid is
transition modelling.
And I, I feel that that's why
the wall-resolved LES is still
very tempting because it doesn't
fully solve it, but it, it
definitely helps to overcome
some of those challenges.
So I think that will continue,
but I would look more at how do
we make wall-resolved LES
approaches more, more
affordable.
I am going to be doing an
episode where we're going to
talk more on the combustion side
of things.
I do realise that this podcast
just tend to be a little bit
focused on external aero.
That's basically my background.
So I am purposely trying to,
yeah, diversify a little bit and
make sure that we're covering
other areas.
And the final one was mergers
and acquisitions and
innovations.
And this has definitely kept
going.
We have seen Ansys and Synopsys,
so two big companies merge.
We have seen, you know Siemens, Altair, Cadence, BETA CAE.
So this has kept going and was a
trend that I predicted and is
still true today that there is
so much interest in the
community and engineering and
semiconductor businesses that,
you know, it's a growing
business, really important.
And big companies are realizing
the value of acquiring or
merging with others to, you
know, bring some of their
technology in and speed up.
You know, that that time.
I think that will continue.
I would say the prediction for
next year, it's not there's not
many other big companies that
can merge now.
You know, it has consolidated a
little bit to Cadence, Siemens
and, and Synopsys, but where I
do see that being definitely
move is there's a lot of
start-ups and I'm sure that the
many of those start-ups will be
acquired by some of these bigger
companies.
So they can start to really
bring those to a more enterprise
level and integrate it.
So I, my prediction would be in
the next 12 months that some of
the start-ups that you, you
know, you may know of, I won't
mention all names, but the
start-ups, you know, I think
you'll see some of them being
acquired by high profile
companies just because that is,
that's a tried and tested route.
You know, when I spoke to the
CTO of Ansys and he openly
admitted it, he said, that's
what we do.
We look for great start-ups.
We may even, you know, encourage
them.
And once they reach a certain
level, we might acquire it.
And it, that's a great way of
developing new technology.
Sometimes it's better to let a
start up do it.
You have a, you know, faster way
of doing than a, let's say, a
big enterprise.
But then they acquire them, they
bring them, and that's how
customers get to use them.
So I think that will also still continue.
So where do I think things are
going?
Well, I think actually those
five topics will still continue
to be a thing for 25 and 26, and
I'm excited to see how they
accelerate.
So I hope that was interesting.
I thought I'd keep it short.
I know these podcasts tend to go
to an hour or two hours, so I
thought I'll keep this one short
and got a couple of really good
guests coming up for the next
two episodes.
So yeah, look out for those.
And for now, I hope you enjoyed
this episode.